okay okay okay that worries that dumb
enough though I don't know that's what
I'm saying I'm afraid they're not gonna
get it like this if you've arrived like
this would you cry of your time the
pianist every 10 bring it back Tim right
fast I'll cry with CRI making up
comments for ygs shoot you didn't know
didn't know that this is how every
episode of your grammar sucks is made we
sit in a circle and make up comments
you're joking nobody gave everything
it's made up then Shawn's supposed to
touch his chest once you wrote this this
isn't really this is Vegas holy thing
you're actually at home editing this
friends I had friends I do
today's edit day would you think about
sketch huh pretty interesting fun while
the grammar was okay I can't say the
same for the logic if you can give us a
guess as to what that F was going on
through that entire process with the
comments coming in I'm writing in myself
it's all in my mind
who knows if you can guess what it was
then you get a hundred Internet points
you're like me you don't care that's
fine too you know say anything just
click like subscribe you know what to do
thanks for watching guys bye bye